[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to think of it hello and
welcome to dear Hank and Flula sorry
John where are you where are you I don't
even know I don't even know what he's up
to
Thank You Flula for joining us this is a
comedy podcast where me and usually my
brother John but today Flula Borg answer
your questions give you dubious advice
and bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey Flula
how you doing I'm so good Hank how are
you doing today I am great I'm so happy
to have you on the podcast to help
answer some people's questions and I'm
sure you're gonna be such a wonderful
purveyor of dubious advice I am love the
doobies yeah so yeah what what are you
up to right now where are you I'm
currently in a town it is called Los
Angeles I'm wearing a small pair of
Underpants no socks and no shirt that's
not really what I asked but thank you
for letting me know anyway of course
what are you wearing Hank I'm wearing a
t-shirt and jeans like I am not wearing
socks though I'm sorry so hot so hot too
hot for podcast too hard for podcast
what kind of Underpants are you wearing
I'm wearing sir the kind that is having
us a slit so if you are needing to use
toilets in the first way you can just go
with that
good night do you by any chance have a
short poem for us today I'd I have
written one just 0.1 seconds ago
the poem is called sandwich okay are you
ready yes here we go mmm look at you
slices mmm
look at you peanuts i squish you and
then put you on the bread and then I and
then I eat you delicious at the end
sounds great send sandwich it's
beautiful thank you for sharing your
short poem for us Flula of course Hank
it's available immediately on a medium
[Laughter]
I feel like that's I feel it that
selling yourself short Flula used maybe
you should just go straight to like
printed page and like sell a pamphlet
with just your poetry so that's very
smart I'm emailing and tweeting Simon
and Schuster right now both of them both
both always both you have to go double
or nothing you know how would they say
it I do oh good
so yeah well well I guess we should
probably start answering questions from
people I love that when this happens on
the podcast with me and you not John do
you have any particularly question that
stuck out to you that you want to answer
I I will go in any direction that you
are I you know like when the man is
driving and the man in the other seat
he's he's riding Ozzy I am you're I'm
riding Guzzi so you you might select
what I'm hearing Flula is that you
haven't really you haven't really read
any of the questions that is accurate
yes all right well this one is from
Amanda who asks dear Hank and Flula why
don't people eat the ends of loaves of
bread what is the need for this
discrimination oh I thought I thought
that was a good good question for you
because you obviously are passionate
about sandwiches I do have passion of
sandwich I have passion of carbohydrates
my answer for Amanda I will say is I do
not discriminate
I do actually I have something reversed
discriminations
I love the ends of the bread because
they are symbolizing a beginning and
also an ending and these are the most
fun parts of movies poems and books and
and sandwiches and die hard movies but
not of life know the beginning of a life
is pretty pretty fun but the end not so
much not very much you are baby once
more but with wrinkles yes yes and then
you and then you have to not exist
anymore
sad that's a sad time do you think a lot
about death Flula I not an you know not
enough I think if I was thinking more
about it I would be doing many more
adventure things you know I would not
worry so much about groceries or am i
properly hydrated things like this I
think it's I think it's very important
to keep properly hydrated but it's yeah
that's that's interesting to hear I
think that often my my other partner on
this podcast John Green he thinks a
little bit too much about death
Oh what what do you mean oh you know
he's just a worrywart ah oh I would
imagine if you are thinking about this
you would say hey I'm perhaps death is
happening let me stop my warts and just
go with pimples of happiness that's yep
aha so I I also I'm surprised to hear
you say that you feel like you don't go
on enough adventures yeah well I think
you know it is supported by blood
pressure and I have measured mine and it
is usual in a healthy range I think this
is a terrible I think you should have
high blood pressure all the time because
of the adventures that are happening not
because of too much sodium okay do you
know what I mean
yes I think I do but I feel like you
lead a very interesting exciting life I
saw you on Conan recent oh it was very
nice I was that was his fun time I'm not
certain how it occurred but hey I loved
it he was very friendly and also a tall
man of height he was she was tall do you
feel like you had high blood pressure
during your Conan O'Brien experience I
experienced yes a slight a slight a
conniption or some some something where
synapses firing in the brain in a
strange location absolute it was very
fun okay good I really enjoyed it if
people who are listening haven't watched
that it is very worth very worth
watching I so Flula are you German
citizen yeah I am a German citizen ready
for the actions do you also have
American citizenship I do not I'm very
jealousy of people well actually I don't
know should I have a jealousy of it oh
well you would be able to vote mmm but
you can't I I cannot vote but I do wish
I could vote for you for you guys yeah
yes we would also I'm sure appreciate
that so we have another question from
Dennis on that in that vein who asked
dear Hank and Flula I'm an American
citizen and this year will be my first
vote ever in an election you guys have
stressed how important it is to vote and
research I'm excited to vote but am
unsure how to do proper research do I
check my congressman's website for their
policy ideas how can I check if the data
is unbiased can i snapchat them after
watching always sunny about immigration
reform Oh Dennis what well Hank is as
you are you are you are American man you
are Yankee Doodle Dandy what what would
you say to this well it's not like you
don't have elections as well in Germany
do you vote in German elections I do
yeah I mean well I can say to Dennis
Dennis I would not snapchat always sunny
for the immigration reform I think this
would not help with the voting this
would help with adding more data bytes
to the Internet traffic but this does
not educate you so I would say maybe
don't do that one so that's my first
note what about you Hank
I I think that it would be good to like
it would be nice if you could snapchat
to a politician and they would snap you
back and I'd be like yeah no I totally
agree with everything you're saying but
I think that you know if you if you
represent a large number of people it's
hard to answer all the snaps that are
coming in true I so so yeah I think that
there are you can both look at the sort
of like the policy ideas of your
Congress people and it's not that you
like can or cannot trust those things I
think that in in many cases what you're
looking at there is you are learning
about not just what they want but sort
of what their values are and like the
direction that they think the country
should go in and if you don't agree with
those things then that you can look at
someone else or if you do but or some of
them but not all of them and that's how
that's gonna part of how you get
informed but I think also there's you
know not just in terms of candidates
there are always things on your ballot
that might throw you for a little bit of
a loop whether they're like you know
it's like local initiatives that are
like we always have somebody who's
trying to do a tax levy like they're
gonna increase taxes for for ten years
by some small amount and we're they're
gonna take that money and they're gonna
make the schools better and but you have
to vote for those things and you have to
decide whether or not you're one of
those people who's like yes I will pay a
little bit extra money for schools or no
I think people should be less smart and
educated if they pick if you pick which
one of those people you want to be so I
don't know that's up to you
and good but yeah I I find that you know
in indeed trusting a politician's policy
statements does make sense it's not
going to tell you like what kind of
person they are it's not gonna
necessarily outlaw and like this person
is definitely not going to be a jerk but
it will tell you if they like what they
want to represent in and and do in the
government aligns with your values dote
and unfortunately you cannot run out and
you know not always sometimes you can
for local elections you can sometimes
even like go to talk to those people
like go to events and ask them questions
and see get a feel for them but you know
you definitely don't have to do that I
think that about an hour's worth of
research with a sample ballot will tell
you you know tell you what you want and
and how to vote wow that was very great
egg I feel very prepared now to do all
the things well good I'm sure that
Germany needs your vote I know that
there are a great many things of
interest and imports happening in
Germany right now yeah it's a crazy
place we do not have two parties that
are doing sassy things we have many many
parties which is nice these are not
parties with hats and salads but you
know like political parties we also have
salad parties as well but we have many
more than you guys at the moment yeah
but you are having some new parties
libertarian not new but they are they
are making some noises the libertarian
Center the greens are doing some things
still that's kind of cool yeah yeah it's
very difficult in the way that our
voting works for other parties to take a
substantial portion of the vote because
they're just not going to actually win
at least not in a national level so
anytime you vote for a third party you
are you are taking votes you are kind of
in effect taking votes away from from
the person who is going to put who has
the higher chance of winning who you
maybe don't feel great about but you
feel better about than the other person
and thus the quandary but yeah it's it's
it definitely in this year we're where
there are two you know fairly unpopular
candidates at the top
the at the top of the the two main
parties yeah it looks like Gary
Johnson's gonna do pretty well for a
third party candidate which has happened
before in the history of America but
yeah not not recently I'm excited I am
NOT excited I dislike this election a
lot and I want it to be over yeah me as
well I mean I'm just a man hanging out
but I am very confused that it is
happening like this was a very strange
situation that we are observing as
Europeans we don't really know how this
has happened it's like a movie that gets
a sequel and then they are still 12 more
sequels and you're like but why are the
sequels coming and then they are still
here and this is so confusing so who
knows I'm excited for it to be done and
you know you think is crossed very hard
do you get you you ask a question okay
how listen oh these are some nice ones
here Oh Riley
here's Riley dear Hank entra nope dear
Hank and Flula when you were discussing
the software update for the Mars rover
and its potential sentience that got me
wondering would it be possible for
someone to hack into a rover on another
planet I don't know why anyone would
want to do that but now I'm just curious
if it is possible thank you for
entertaining this ridiculous question I
love the podcast Hank you are a sassy
muffin of studs Thank You Riley that's
very kind
yeah yes yes it is possible to hack I
would I would say that it's like it's
possible to hack anything but you can
send like NASA sends not just like
messages to tell the rover what to do
but it sends like firmware upgrades and
software upgrades like it will send an
entire new operating system to the rover
have it turn off and reboot with a new
operating system so you could basically
do whatever you want if you could get
figure out how NASA sends the signals
both practically like physically which
is I'm sure a very large antenna with a
huge amount of energy behind it because
it
to send all the way to Mars so you would
have to build one of those or hack into
NASA's oh and then you would have to
sort of like like look at what the
message is that NASA sends and either
know how the software works because you
work at NASA or sort of reverse engineer
what like what protocols they're using
and what programming language they're
using I'm sure that like you like it's
public knowledge what what operating
system it's based on and what what what
programming language they use but I
don't know if it's if it's like the
protocol is probably aren't public
knowledge so it would be a lot of work
and you would be able to maybe hack into
a Mars rover and tell it to do something
but please don't don't do it because
they know what they're doing it's pretty
expensive thing and that would be mean I
I would think that if anybody did hack
into the Mars rover I have to be like
state state sponsored kind of like
terrorism thing like you I feel like
North Korea doing it yeah yeah it or
perhaps just not even sponsored
terrorist just sponsored rudeness you
know it's really this could be rude but
I will tell you Riley I have Google
searched and the Mars rover runs on
Windows 98 so just so you know and so
that's very exciting yes good I I would
have assumed maybe a boon to but Oh like
a Linux some kind of Linux ah yeah yeah
yeah Red Hat
Red Hat all right we've got another
question do you want to hear it a so bad
so bad here's another question it's from
Elijah who asks dear Hank and John what
is the function of the holes in
cheez-its and most most other crackers
for that matter other than to rob me of
cheesy substance that is rightfully mine
oh so you're saying that like they make
the hole and they're like haha Elijah's
not gonna get this bit of Jesus no I I
must tell a lie I know why this is Hank
it may I'd me I - yes yes and okay so do
you know like if you are in a saran wrap
bag
and pretending that you are let us say
you are a piece of chocolate and it is
just no air is in the bag okay okay can
you can you smell it what is what is HAP
can you smell this
this chocolate KMI the chocolate no you
are human who's looking at the chocolate
okay so there's a chocolate in the saran
wrap bag no holes no holes and very
tight no oxygen is inside okay God can
you can you smell this chocolate no can
you enjoy the chocolate in a tasty way
not unless I cut up in a saran wrap ha
ha
to enter the oxygen which helps to make
smells and tastes and these are the
holes purposes the holes in that in the
cracker are letting the oxygen touch the
cheese and massage it in science ways so
when you put it in your mouth then you
can taste it more delicious if it was no
holes there would be no flavor
Alijah you know and that's why the sides
that's the science I disagree with you
huh well science is malleable so I I
think I have another suggestion okay
that if you if you bake a cracker yeah
which is just sort of like a piece of
bread right and if you throw it in there
yeah it's gonna like puff up and get me
a cup like so like think about a
goldfish yeah like a goldfish is a crack
with no no with no holes in it it's just
cut into a goldfish no good well yeah no
but it like it's sort of like puffed up
right so I think like that with a cheese
that are a Saltine like you see where
the dot is is sort of flat and then it
puffs up around that but if the dot
wasn't there then it'd just be puffing
up all around and it'll be like ice like
a like a weird a weird sphere thing
instead of like a flat cracker thing so
they poke the holes in so that the steam
can escape when it while it's baking so
it doesn't puff it up into one of the
into like a puff pastry with a big big
bunch of air in the middle ah
that's that's my thought as to why they
put holes in cheeses but I like oxygen
massages have you ever had an oxygen
massage I have one every day it is why I
am 84% nudity right now I'm just feeling
the oxygens massaging my epidermis good
it's good so like any nearby thing that
likes Flula the way that Flula likes
chocolate can smell welcome to me Oh
does you do you ever fear that you'll be
eaten by a bear
I only fear this if I'm in a forest and
it is very dark and I am covered in
chocolate and that happens how often
zero times in my life how about you Hank
also zero times in my life but the word
that you said it it made me think maybe
it was like it was like you're another
version of an oxygen massage for you
chocolate massage oh no no it's a dream
I have a dream this is a like every
month or maybe two months I have a
chocolate bear forest dream I thought
that it was a dream like not like it
like what happens at night but the like
your aspirations for the future Oh like
a goal like my vision my vision board
yeah it was on my vision board which was
a cartoon rendering of my body covered
in white chocolate and then a beer
oh my chocolate white chocolate of
course white chocolate which really is
not real chocolate which is why the the
base don't care I mean they're because
they're they're rational beings and they
understand the way that everyone else
does that white chocolate it's just a
just a dangerous lie I agree oh hey I
just remembered the real reason of
cheesy cheesy cracker holes oh yeah
necklaces necklace necklace what is the
plural of necklaces yes I think it's
necklaces necklaces is the reason so
there we there you go in Asha are we
still on Elijah or have we moved on but
I will never move on from Elijah that's
right that's right
yeah I okay good do you have I think we
should though okay let's move okay
bye-bye
but but if anybody out there wants to
send us pictures of you wearing a
cheez-it necklace we will look at them
and maybe even put them on our patreon
page oh all the patreon swill enjoys
this picture I will I will and then
afterward you can just eat it you can
walk around all day with your cheez-it
necklace and nibble nibble and always
have a snack with you I think a great
idea
portable jewelry snacks this is a market
niche Hank it's a market niche all right
hit us with another question Flula great
grace writes dear Hank and Flula hello
I was recently staying in a hotel and
after a long day of sights
I went down to the hotel pool and also
hot tap I got into the hot tap but then
five minutes later a large family with
many small children entered the premises
this very much stressed me out my
question is what is the proper hotel hot
tub etiquette II I really just want to
relax and peace and quiet but when is it
acceptable to get up and leave if
someone is joining you I don't want to
offend please help me
healthy very much grace so I assume that
this whole family came and joined in the
hot tub or were they just around I
imagine it was like the toes and calves
and purposes of a large family like many
humans in the in the top well I grace I
think there's two options here or I
guess three one is to just sit silently
and stay in the hot tub and not interact
with your new friends two is to just
leave which is also completely
acceptable three is to engage your new
friends in conversation and be like hey
we are enjoying a hot tub together
I feel like option one is very weird but
I think option two or three are both
fine you can you know like if they enter
they don't know how long you've been in
the hot tub maybe you've been in the hot
tub for an amount of time that is
dangerous so you must leave the hot tub
whether or not they had arrived so
they're not gonna feel offended if
you're like oh I've finished my hot tub
time and you move along and and I
imagine they also won't feel offended if
you're like hey where are you guys from
I'm visiting from Alberta and hot tub do
you often come to hot tubs but I do
think that like you can't sort of like
stake claim on a hot tub at a hotel and
be like I was here first
so get your calves and pelvises out of
this hot tub family of many people you
cannot do it I will tell to you Hank my
strategy I I stare at the toes of the
people walking and if the toes are
looking clean I shall stay in the pool
if the toes are looking funky I shall
make a pretend of a phone call that I
have just received in my head or also
I or in the sky and I will pretend
someone is calling me and I will just
run and scream well what what has
happened on the phone that makes you run
in scream I say oh is it is it true oh
no and then I leave okay
okay yeah and then I apologize to those
guys so sorry so sorry large family BRB
but then I never RB do you know what I
mean
I know exactly what you mean I think I
think that's a great plan and I don't
know that it's necessary but I think
that the checking out of the toes is a
really good is a really good thought so
I agree thank you for that one also us
maybe if you just stare at their feet
for long enough they'll get the point
and they'll leave themselves like
they'll be like why is this person such
a foots terror this is making me very
uncomfortable
so they invaded your hot tub and made
you uncomfortable so you got to get them
back and be like but yeah feet toes
toenails yeah I think if you also
mumbles those words
yeah feet toes toenails this also works
if you repeat it perfect yes now I got
it got another question we're fine
through him Flula we are good at this oh
I love it got another question from
Maggie who asks dear Hank and Flula help
I've scheduled for a colonoscopy in a
few weeks and I'm incredibly nervous
about it I've never gone through a
medical procedure of this magnitude and
I'm not looking forward to having my
body both drugged didn't medically
invaded this isn't even to mention the
preparation that goes the day before do
you have any dubious advice on how I can
be less freaked out about the whole
situation
oh boy Maggie this sounds very exciting
I would say to Maggie if she's having a
favorite song and a favorite snack and
also a favorite pair of socks
who wears a socks eats a snack listen to
the song and and repeat like the
shampoos well I my I do have one problem
with this is the because I've you've
never had a colonoscopy obviously but
you can't eat you can't eat anything
Oh the day before though you can have
like lime jello or something
so well I'm jello happens to be one of
your favorite snacks do go ahead yeah oh
thanks Hank
Maggie I hope you like lime jell-o just
just shove it into your mouth just eat
many leaders yeah I have had several
colonoscopies and what yes and I would
you only have one colon yes but
different times not at the same time got
it okay
and I will say that it's not so bad
you're right the prep the day before is
the worst part make sure that you
refrigerate that stuff before you drink
it because drinking it warm is the end
of the end of days but one of my
favorite things in the world
my favorite sensations in the whole
world is the drug that they give you
right before you get a colonoscopy I
would definitely be addicted to that
drug if I if I could be and it's it
makes you feel very good in the three
seconds before you are unconscious but
it's almost worth the entire experience
for me and I know that I am I'm
basically talking up illegal drugs right
now but it's it's almost worth the
entire experience to get for those three
seconds of of what must be just like
what what people feel when they are the
happiest they've ever been oh so don't
don't try and get that stuff in a
non-medical situation because it would
definitely be something that wouldn't
would not and then there's the hole
afterwards which is very full but well
it's a very normal procedure that lots
of people have done to them and it's
it's you know my first my first
colonoscopy I was freaked out and I
didn't like it and then now it's just
sort of like a thing that happens and I
don't mind at all it's kind of like it's
kind of like a couple of days out of my
schedule that I can't like do stuff but
so totally worth it for you know for
telling your doctor what your doctor
needs to know about your body
so what you're saying Hank is to enjoy
these drugs you should treat your body
in a way that requires a colonoscopy
that's legal this is sleek listen I need
this colonoscopy now give me these
delicious drugs that's what you're
saying uh yeah no okay don't do that
don't okay
I said almost not vogue total not
entirely worth it not worth it
god it's so close to so close to worth
it but not quite right to where got it
okay good
got it great thanks this is exciting
yeah thank you I'm so excited for my
first good :
for my first scoping yeah now uh and
yeah they put a camera up you but have
you ever have you ever oh I had why do
they want so why do they do so they can
look around inside of your colon and see
if there's anything wrong what does this
have to do with a colonoscopy that's
what it is say what they put a camera in
your anus yeah it's like on a snake it's
like a like a like a like a camera tube
they play feet up there they put a snake
up your anus with a camera yes basically
it's it's like a little snake like
pretty thin
okay I mean it can bend itself and look
around and it even has a little tool on
it to like remove things if they need to
take a biopsy or remove a polyp
oh great got like a little we've got a
little laser beam on it to cauterize
where they've removed a thing
so okay yeah well it's a laser camera
snake perfect I am Maggie very excited
for you enjoy the drugs I would say this
would be a very fun time just everything
that Hank said for the last 60 seconds
don't listen to that it's my advice to
you Maggie
okay I am I'm now sealing my anus as we
speak so this will never happen to me so
I am safe I think that if you I think if
you seal your anus up you're gonna need
a colonoscopy pretty quick oh okay this
is very this is so keep it open
counterfeit over there okay okay the
hole I'm widening my holes now it's from
Zach who asks dear Hank and John I'm
considering using 23andme to get my
personal genetic information I'm very
curious to learn about my ancestor
however I'm worried that my genetic code
will reveal that I have a gene
associated with a disease I don't want
the results to depress me but at the
same time I realized that my fear of a
negative result is irrational since
learning about it won't change it in
fact learning about a genetic risk might
help me take steps to avoid it have you
ever considered getting a personal
genetic information test and do you have
any w's advice for me oh that's from
Zach Wow
do you have you ever have you ever
thought about having your genomes genome
I think that my genome I have not but I
imagine I should I wouldn't maybe like
to know but I don't care so much I think
if like I was feeling funky junky and
like why do I feel so funky junky maybe
it's in my genome then I would do it
but I'm feeling pretty good so I don't
care but if you just said hey hey Flula
guess what he is your genome infos I
would be kind of excited mm-hmm you
it'll tell you about your ends like
that's mostly what what 23 me is about
it's like telling you sort of where
you're from and oftentimes it's like if
you're in America it's like you are some
part German but it'd be weird if you
were German and they're like you are not
all German oh that would be strange yeah
yeah that's I'm sure you aren't I'm apt
well no one is right I mean it's like
when it's like a hot dog right how much
of the hot dog it is is beef I think
it's like 3% is beef and the 97% is like
happiness or something
I have not you do you know what may know
anything about your ancestry I know it
is German with lots of Germans and a
sprinkling of German but I imagine also
there must be some tiny doses of French
or Viking or you know who knows some
something interesting Antarctic
antarctic Kinz something like that what
about you Hank who who are you I don't
know that's that's one reason why I
would be interested because like my
family you know it branches off so
quickly and then like you you completely
lose track and I yeah I mean all of the
people all of my grandparents you know
their their grandparents I don't know if
all of their grandparents but all of my
grandparents parents were and we're
American so I don't have any like recent
immigrants in my family
but I'm from a lot of me is from the
south of America which means not South
America but the south of the US where
there's a lot of like Irish there's a
lot of there it's a lot of you I'm very
European is my guess but I would love to
know more I've seen your face and and
you know your your legs and torso I
would imagine you are European well when
did you swear did you see my torso in a
dream is a dream I was in a forest and
then the bear is there and then you are
you are holding a large lead you are
holding a large bucket of white
chocolate okay this dream is this dream
is going directions I didn't you didn't
mention that the first time it's a
detail I did not want to share with you
but because we are speaking about
23andme I was thinking 23 and why not I
will tell Hank well thank you I i I'm
you're welcome you know I think honesty
is the best policy
really though like for sure mmm I mean
maybe not when it's about a weird bear
dream and I'm I'm you know my torso is
out and I've got a bucket of white
chocolate but like usually yeah I'm
regretting this honesty yeah well you
know I'm not gonna I'm not gonna let it
get weird between us thanks Hank
yeah hey shall I wait read a question
sure okay hey oh we didn't even answer
Zach's question I'll add to Zach it's
123 and me isn't gonna tell you a lot
about a genetic diseases unless they are
very significant and those are things
that you should know about for sure
because you can indeed be proactive
about the diseases that you are
genetically either predisposed to or are
definitely going to get and so yeah
there's nothing wrong with that and yes
nice
don't worry yeah you'll and and what
I'll think about what how great it'll be
to know that you don't have those
diseases which is the most likely yes
nice work Hank playing the odds
that's good yeah shall I read a question
I'm so excited
yes Hank and Flula I am cheap and don't
enjoy sugar beverages
this is Ben who is typing so when I go
eat at a food establishment I rarely
order a soft drink for you but hardrick
it could work then when I go to a
fast-food restaurant I ask for a cup of
water and when possible I fill the small
cups I give me with mmm carbonated water
from the drinking fountain using the
little tabby thing what what what Oh
tisk tisk Benjamin am i stealing or is
it acceptable to drink this sparkler
water since no one in their right mind
would pay for soda and get sparkling
soda water at least not in America what
do you think guys love always been shout
out so I I do this too and yeah I think
that is the subject of much contention
I paid for soda water which I dislike
doing and it almost to me seems like I'm
doing something like stupid not wrong
but dumb because clearly the soda like
soda water costs a little bit more than
water because they have to carbonate it
so they have to like replace the
carbonation cylinders but I can't
imagine that it cost more than like five
cents so like paying for a soda and then
getting soda water is not a good deal
for me okay ever when I buy soda water
at the store like if I get a lacroix
then then like I'm paying roughly
similar amounts as if I worth buying
like a 12-pack of cokes so it it it's I
I think that it is probably a subject of
much debate and I would be interested to
hear if like fast-food employees are
trained in a specific circumstance like
no they are not allowed to get soda
water if they just order water and I
don't know like if it was like there are
some places where there's like Seagram's
club soda and then you're getting that
and for some reason that seems better
like let it's better to pay for that
even though it's just bubbly water I'd
pretty sure they're not putting anything
in that Sukhram club soda it's just it's
just the stuff it's just the sauce yeah
but it's got a brand on it so it feels
more like it's okay to pay for it and
not just like a tabby thing which feels
like
and also like got to say that the water
cost the money to not just not just a
lot like but like the you know you're
getting at you getting ice in the water
then like the ice custom electricity and
yelling the water down costs money so I
don't know like it's it is a weird
it is a weird gray area in the world of
soft drinks I
I like your points of ice it costs money
to make ice but they do not charge you
for the ice when you ask for ice water
so oh I said but my here's my simple
answer to Ben if it is the little tabby
then it is free if it is a big tabby
then you must pay the dollars but if
it's a tiny tabby it means who cares
that's that that is the message I think
they are sending to to the humans
purchasing liquids I want to know what
the official McDonald's policy is on
this oh yeah me as well what does what
does Ray Kroc think I would like to know
Ray Kroc is the founder of McDonald's
you know the name of the math founder of
McDonald's yeah you don't know this I
did not know that yeah where did where
did you is that is that something that's
taught in German schools no I just read
things and so like when you walk into
sometimes the McDonald's it's like a you
know like a plaque it's like shout out
man who made special sauce and also
invented our restaurant Ray Kroc no no
man look at that
I'm looking at a picture of him right
now yeah yeah he's a man and teammate
McDonald's sorry yeah yeah he also he
also founded a hamburger University
which I want which I want to know about
is that and I don't know I will check
let me check typey typey no no it is not
it is an Oak Brook very different very
different yeah that's very exciting nice
work ray kroc with your hamburger you
yes indeed you can learn all about how
to work in McDonald's there yeah I like
I had never considered how like I feel
like important this question is it's
just people people don't talk about it
and I think that club soda is totally
sort of water totally the direction we
should all be going in because I like it
yeah and it's fun
yeah and it's guys not just water
No yeah but it doesn't have all the
weirdness in it yeah yeah do you know it
but you'd if you remember Shakespeare
bubbles bubbles toil and troubles mr. so
kicked out of McDonald's yeah this
troubles cause of the bubbles
Shakespeare he was very he knew it he
saw it now I feel bad for going to
McDonald's and and paying for my soda
water don't know you're helping you're
helping Hank I'm helping who McDonald's
your levels of guilt if you had these
all these times if you had not paid you
would have tiny guilty feelings inside
your brain and now you don't have those
now you just feel like a silly goose and
that's ok right yeah no yep I mean
there's there it's I don't know which
was those feelings is worse oh no
stealing from McDonald's is never gonna
make me feel that bad true yeah I agree
Ray Kroc doesn't Kia no definitely not
that only not that's what I got a
question for you Flula whoo it's uh
we're gonna do we should probably just
do one more question
it's from Rachael who asks dear Hank and
John I just found out my cousin who
lives fairly far away in a different
country just named her newborn girl the
same name me and my husband had picked
out for our baby due in January and I
still use the name yes at a silent age
someplace after of our yeah there every
name has an alternate spelling now don't
worry yes you could you could spell it
every way and as long as you have like
put down oh it's pronounced like Jenny
but it's spelled D H a n oo I but it's
pronounced Jenny Jenny that's you to
spell Jenny right yes
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so see it
yeah I want to know what the name is if
it's weird enough I feel like maybe not
but you know this is a cousin and this
is a faraway country I think it's fine
oh oh no wait wait wait I have
discovered an intricacy to this question
that I did not say out
I have my cousin lives fairly far away
in a different country just named her
newborn girl the same name me and my
husband had picked out for our baby boy
due in January I also think that's still
fine just to be clear but I have not I
had not accurately portrayed thee the
such I am so excited to hear this name
like what is the names that they would
like for a lady but also for a boy
I am excited oh but there's no that's
why I'm curious I would like it to be
one that is not good for both Flula did
you know yeah this is this is a weird
bit of trivia Jessie's Girl you know the
song judge that she wishes that she was
that girl and how can I find a woman
like that now he wishes that he held
Jessie is sad cuz his skirt yeah I know
it yeah he's and he's sick yeah but
where's Jessie and I where did you go
Jessie yeah Brighton Jessie's Girl was
named Jessie was so so messy and Jessie
yeah cuz Jessie Jessie's both a boy and
a girl name and it's a little-known fact
that Jesse was dating a girl named
Jessie and that's Ric Ocasek really
wanted Jessie but not the Jessie whose
jet who was the one with the girl but he
was girl named Jessie he should very
much change the title of the song or
something you know like this is
confusing which that's why he just left
it out cuz it cuz like yeah like I'm
writing this song and I don't want to
like talk about Jesse and Jesse so I'll
just leave out Jesse who is just a girl
I wish that I had Jessie's Girl who is
also named Jessie
Jessie's Girl is also Jessie that's how
it originally went that was the original
version of that song and and the rest of
the cars were like no Rick this is this
is ludicrous yeah stop it stop this
immediately Rick okay I like this thank
you Hank I feel like I have learned a
thing now alright well this this podcast
we're gonna do now flew a thing where we
talked about who brought this podcast
two of the people Oh
so this podcast is brought to you by
Jessie's Girl Jesse Jesse who is
Jessie's Girl really actually likes
Jesse and so Rick should probably just
mind his own
I agree step away Rick from all of the
Jesse's yes does Jesse it's confusing
yeah yeah just I was gonna I was gonna
go deeper but that I don't know what to
say cause it's just too many Jesse's so
many Jesse's it's a it's a chorus of
Jesse's yes okay who do you who else
brought the podcast to us oh this was
also brought to us by crunchy peanut
butter something to put in your mouth
and chew up in town and send swallow and
enjoy as it goes down to your colon and
helps the snake with the laser vodcast
is also brought to you by a giant bucket
of melted white chocolate with a ladle
in it oh that's very delicious in the
forest with the bear hmm
that's a very exciting thing and also
this podcast it's brought to you by the
hopes and dreams of a tiny chipmunk what
did the little hope syndrome of tiny
shrimp or never have a tag line that
they've asked us to include in the
podcast
oh yeah the tag line of the Hope Center
of the chipmunk was don't don't don't go
chasing waterfalls and also don't it
carbonate your water all right hmm
that's good to know what what uh what
many Chipmunks are really thinking about
so let's let's go ahead and do the Mars
from new then Mars from news the news
from Mars and Effie's please most from
news all right do you want to know some
Mars news please share me or the Martian
times well
the Mars Curiosity rover just celebrated
its fourth birthday on the surface of
Mars at the the team is now able to do
in a week what used to take them a month
because they have just gotten super good
at running the run in the system and
refined a lot of the the protocols and
curiosity four years later continues to
do a bunch of amazing things on Mars and
all of its equipment
is still functioning which is fantastic
nothing has totally broken yet some of
the wheels are a little bit worse for
wear but they've done a bunch of they've
done a bunch of tests on a sort of
sister over here on earth to make sure
that they used the wheels in ways that
will keep them alive through the end of
the curiosity Rover's mission and also
every year on its birthday the day at
which it has been on Mars for another
year Curiosity rover will sing to itself
the Happy Birthday song and I think
that's just adorable
that it sings the little happy birthday
song out loud on the surface of Mars to
itself with no one around that is not
sad in any way that is very great and
positive I'm not depressed to hear about
this
DJ actually asked us a question if that
happens in earth years or Mars years and
it does indeed happen in earth years but
but DJ doesn't think that that makes any
sense because it seems very odd he says
to celebrate one's birthday on someone
else's terms because the Mars Curiosity
rover is more martian than than than
Earth because it's lived on Mars longer
than it lived on earth so yeah it's an
it's a Mars native maybe it should be
going by Mars New Year's now but it was
born you cannot forget your hometown you
were it was born in on earth it was not
like they tube two robots did not
intercourse in this space and then and
then poop out the Curiosity bad like at
what point do you become a native of a
new land do you become like do you
become a citizen of that place I think
that's an interesting and uncomplicated
question from DJ and we're probably not
gonna tackle it here on this podcast do
you have any news from AFC Weldon for us
it is so funny that you have asked about
AFC Wimbledon a third tier English
soccer team but yes I know all about the
news of this guy so you're ready yeah oh
boy
such great news AFC Wimbledon has
officially played the first game in
league one and it did not go super well
but it did go very dramatically which is
nice because
liar Taylor and Chris Webb Dale they
both scored and at one point that dance
were winning two to one but oh boy so
sad
Peter's burro tied the game and then in
the 93rd minute brought it to three to
two and Wimbledon they just lost the
game they lost it they lost it Hank
but was an even game though because it
showed potential promise for the club's
future in their new league I am so proud
of all the A's F census of Wimbledon
nice work thank you that you are so well
informed on AFC Wimbledon Flula I am an
encyclopaedia Wimble Tanika this is
lovely thank you so much and what what a
spectacular thing I guess that's too bad
in the 93rd minute that's like after the
game should have ended oh right it's if
someone is injured and they are making
spray paint on the ankle and then BOOM
oh it's very sad I am sorry sorry it's a
good good first try so AFC Wimbledon is
now down at the bottom of the league one
table but there's only been one game
played so it's not a big deal no great
well this was lovely Flula what did we
learn today on the podcast I learned so
many things I learned what a curse when
the snake goes up with with the camera
up your hole and that's exciting I
learned about bubbles and waters and and
and also was a software operating system
of of satellites in space what did you
learn today I learned let's see I
learned that the holes and cheez-its are
for making necklaces with your necklace
neckline necklace eye necklace on it and
then you have a weird weird feeling
about chocolate and hot and white
chocolate and bears in the forest yeah
and I learned that if there is a person
coming up to your hot tub that the most
important thing that you need to do is
look at their toes yeah how immediately
look at those toes check out those toes
you guys because not a lot and not only
do you have the benefit of potentially
seeing
that a thing that you don't want to be
in the same pool of boiling water with
but also maybe if you look hard enough
they will feel maybe like they should
not be hanging out in the hot tub
haha secret strategy right this one now
toenails whoo I love it Wow Hank I feel
so much more intelligent yes I think
that we made the whole world more
intelligent Flula
great work thanks for listening and
thank all of you who are listening for
listening this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins our intern is Claudia
Morales
rosianna halse rojas helps out with the
questions our theme music is from Ghana
gunnarolla if you want to send us
questions for dear Hank and John for
Hank and John to answer you can send
them to Hank and John at gmail.com and
and as they say in our hometown fluid do
you know what they say in our hometown
they say zoo time is here now that
someone's dead okay dads don't forget to
be awesome as what they don't dftb
babies